[Music]  Mel Gibson also gotten a nomination it  was his first Oscar nominee just says  winning twice for Braveheart 21 years  ago but that is not even the biggest  news in his life right now  Mel also became a dad for the ninth time  the Best Director nominee for hacksaw  Ridge tells ET today quote what could be  more exciting than listening to the  nominations being announced while  holding my newborn son girlfriend Roslyn  Ross gave birth to Lars Gerard Gibson in  LA on Friday he weighed in at 5 pounds 5  ounces she's absolutely you I know I  spoke with the 61 year old and his  26-year old lady earlier this month I  was talking to Clint the other day how  many kids you got anyway so I'm beating  him here's number 9 yeah how does it  feel to be beating Clint that's a weird  question well for the record Gibson has  six other sons with ex-wife Robin Moore  they also have one daughter Hannah who  is Mel's oldest at 36 his other daughter  is with ex Oksana  [Music]  you